ciao ragazzi benvenuti alla nuova
puntata di cucina buttata quella di oggi
è una puntata pazzesca rivoluzionarie
oggi faremo i biscotti della fortuna
saranno personalizzabili se avete le
feste dei vostri figli l'avvio al
nubilato no party per i vostri 18 anni e
la media li ha tentennato no ho qui la
ricetta zucchero 110 grammi farina 25
centimetri e amido di mais sette schizzi
ok va bene perfetto siamo pronti
[Musica]
farina zucchero farina di riso amido di
mais aroma di vaniglia e gli albumi di
due o fa e fa tanto qui dicono di
mettere a 170 gradi il forno statico
raga io sto posso dire che sto forno non
l'ho capito ancora che
non sapeva dove lo assiste maniera
aspettami può fare mi porti con favore
il la scala più impervia comunque della
storia che io sono un po distratto da
questa ricetta possa avere è perché
impegnati da ashley price al capito
tutto dalla vita niente stare qua bocca
così e poter rifare tutto apro butto qui
gli albumi i tuorli dietro ci siamo resi
conto ha spento sto coso quindi non lo
stiamo riavviando è bellissimo possiamo
iniziare perfetta la possiamo iniziare
leggendo i vostri commenti so che molti
distrae un sacco questa rosa di lato
perché non seguito è più il video
eseguite loro perfetto in futuro io
conto di stare così
ma ragazzi cioè però vedremo serietà a
sto punto aggiungiamo lo zucchero
112 grammi e senza montare unisco
fingiamo l'olio album e su zucchero cioè
questa ricetta potrebbe riuscire
questo è terribile quanto sembra album e
zucchero e olio
io ti ho insegnato una tecnica per
girare che in uno stato utilizzato è
così
come dovrei chiederlo a craco che pago
il polso viene insegnata che così si
lavava decorso è aspetta finisce a quale
le mani già battezzati e come fosse dome
mica posso
solo fare il cucchiaio di segrate ti
pieghi tutti si no l'oracolo
[Musica]
[Risate]
vado il momento così qui dice di
stendere gli almeno dieci centimetri di
diametro ci serve un righello uno sa
quanti sono dieci centimetri un utilizzo
improprio del paper posso dire ho
sbagliato
speravo di farlo entrare di più non
informate più di due dischi alla volta
bene intanto andiamo tedesca la fortuna
aiuta gli audaci
ti chiedo a tutti quanti di mettere qua
sotto dei commenti che possono entrare
nei bigliettini in modo che così non ci
dobbiamo stare il cervello veniva
direttamente sotto il video sono morbidi
la
[Musica]
c mostre in chiudo chiudo malati
bruciano chiudo mi chiamasse scritto
sono un po friabili ni quando poi vai a
fare questo si crepa si creano delle
crepe esatto
non è giusto vogliamo dichiarare il
fallimento
voglio un attimo modificare un paio di
dosi e
vado un pochino più di albume e teniamo
o meno in forma
io sono tuo padre
assolutamente di pancia senza la minima
consapevolezza e conoscenza di cosa
accada in un forno veramente andiamo a
togliere un po così vediamo
eh sì stupenda e si non rica si è
ridotto no non sono così elastici
prendiamo con una nuova ricetta
[Musica]
questa terza ricetta cosa prevede l'uso
di queste cose qua vi consiglio di
procurarveli vi lascio qui sotto il link
affiliato con gli elmo quanto mi piace
la tua marchi a ho provato una volta ho
subito abbandonato e stacco su instagram
cretini tuoi sogni amica sapevano subito
i tuoi sogni ma mica il primo fallimento
tu devi girarti e metterti a piagne
contro il muro è così che poi diventi
graziana raga l'ha visto per un odio nei
miei confronti incomprensibile anche
giustificato è salegrosso salegrosso
appena pasta
io me ne vado fate la sfida solo
graziana sto per prenderlo
vado avanti
balls puno vanilla di parlare inglese mi
però una mezza tazza di farina mezza
tazza di zucchero
qui mi dice che dovrebbe fare una cosa
che non sta facendo parlare weekend è
così lontano younes atto nel aspettavo
due breaks non fanno un arco anche se
molti sembra che parlino di droga e tipo
una patata
droga quindi qualunque canzone legata al
tema della felicità del re la droga 8
minuti brad sennò più di tutto è bene la
prova che in alto sto modem fallimento
dietro l'altro
vediamo che con te bruciato prendo un
biglietto hicks no
[Musica]
ma l'impasto e quello nuovo con
l'aggiunta di un pochino più di farina 8
fa intanto prego vi prego prego varie
funzioni giorgio più sembrano più pc
cosi degli altri quest'inter fortuna
anzi ciò sta spatola che potrebbe essere
gestito
aspettiamo finché non si sembrano
mezz'oretta
siamo andati avanti nel tempo e dopo
un'ora e mezza qualcosina di più di
attesa erano ancora mosci e per un
momento mi sono detto mollo col cazzo le
o infilati in forno nella speranza di
asciugarli in qualche modo di seccarli
forno statico e il forno ventilato che
secca ma se provassimo ad andarli a
comprare al giapponese qua vicino a
quando non riuscire a realizzare i
vostri sogni compratevi che bella che
per la gara
belle le forme bello dotto io sono stato
due e mezzo alla mia vita a fare una
cosa fallimentare nakata questo però c'è
il segno una cosa molto importante che i
sogni a volte non sono fatti per essere
esauditi ragazzi è la vera domanda da
farsi per quante volte riusciremo a
sbattere la testa contrasto muro e
riprenderci
quand'è che saremo stanchi di farsi male
poi c'è stato fatto di domani ma nigeria
ragazzi a questo punto chiederei a la
linea graziana alessandro e enrico di
scegliere il proprio biscotto della
sfortuna e leggerlo io cresco questo
va ieri col padre mi sentirete crocchi
ma non ci credo
quindi i nostri sogni si sono non è
proprio il lancio biglietto e rompe i
[ __ ] la differenza tra te e l'iraq è
che le vaga il cofano
dovessi trovarti sul vocabolario come
sinonimo di
se la vita avesse non varrebbe la pena
viverla
grazie grazie veramente questo
licenziata
suo ritiro le tue battute e faticoso
quanto frate
anch'io un biglietto della fortuna
rendese anche tu l'ho preparato con
fatto
[Applauso]
no grazie
viaggia rinata dopo il secondo palo
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video mi raccomando iscrivetevi
al canale e lasciateci qua sotto un
commento con una frase da mettere
all'interno dei nostri biscotti della
sfortuna in futuro per quando li
dovremmo fare 45
sono strozzato su credete sempre in voi
stessi noi ci vediamo domenica prossima
con un nuovo video di cucina buttata
sempre mali 12 ciao
[Musica]
[Applauso]